[Music]
working woman so i have to go to work i
have to go to my office i gotta run but
on the way out i'll show you guys one of
my prized possessions
[Music]
damn dude
that's an estate
what is about to happen it just like has
like a dolly forward into that door yeah
one of my prized possessions
you
[Laughter]
i've always been a car girl i love cars
and i really wanted something different
like oh my god
it's not even like they [ __ ] reveal
some classic car that's hard it's the
most expensive possible car yeah
these are the cream mobiles so i did all
gray cars instead of my typical matte
silver that i used to do i put out my
three faves my lamborghini urs
oh really cool which has this kit on the
front of it so it looks a little
different and my rolls-royce is great
also it's a ghost
it has like the cutest little crystal
lady and i just think that's so unique
and then my favorite baby ever ever ever
is the maybach sedan
i love everything about it i love
painting like the emblem gray if i were
to pick one
that's my baby right there
why does she have more passion talking
about this car than her scrapbooks
it's the first time i've really seen her
smile yeah thank you guys so much for
coming into my home to check out some of
my thank you guys so much for coming in
the cream house that is hilarious man
damn i was ready to be very jealous
she's like i have this
one of one porsche 918 that's not legal
in america and you're like [ __ ]
[ __ ] that it's cool
god damn it but no it's just like this
is my default skin lamborghini urus oh
yeah who cares see danny bill's house at
least there are things there that are
like yeah yeah ab rigs for example
fabric yeah devery that looks like that
car exactly yeah dude his house should
be the call should be called the cream
house if you think about it yeah cause
he creams all the time yes with multiple
women so sick he has a free clinic in
his home yeah like he has an actual like
std testing because of all visibility
the creaming he'd be doing yeah isn't it
funny how like you see people with so
much money it's like oh you don't know
how to spend that [ __ ]
what do you mean like just rich people
like you look at some of them you're
like you have no idea what to do with
that you do the lamest [ __ ] possible
with that money but what would you do
[ __ ] paintball field personal
rollercoaster that's what danny b did
that's what the cream goat did i mean i
guess that's why he's the goat that's
why he's the goat he's the only one he's
one of the few to do it right see i look
at something like a paintball field i'm
like that's [ __ ] stupid i'd use that
once
once and then i just that's the point of
being rich though is you you have so
much money you're like i have this thing
i only use
that's sick if i'm rich as [ __ ] it's
like
what's the closest i can get to a mini
water park
like that's cool yeah mini wave pool
some crazy ass slide that goes into the
wave pool now you're yeah yeah
yes see yes okay like come on man that
[ __ ] in like when you go to thailand and
they have like that you know
uh like
40-foot
like wave machine where you can ride
like a shitty ass wave that's what i
mean yeah once you [ __ ] have one of
those yes that that [ __ ] i would i would
do i feel see
not i got my gray lamborghini [ __ ] out
of here
yeah pickleball court yeah um a bunch of
board apes um like cool [ __ ] uh i don't
know [ __ ] uh let's get that [ __ ] dude
um
let's get [ __ ] uh handle roy
i don't know i get like a wu-tang plaque
i'll buy that [ __ ] wu tang record
invite all my [ __ ] friends over to my
listening room right smoke tons of kush
he's sick
i get a cush room dude yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah and what would it look like
just green too much green just weed
leaves yeah just so tacky yeah
unbelievably tacky yo welcome to the
cushion free weed leaf socks yeah for
everyone
yeah that's tight i think i'd build a
med man just into my place yeah
yeah
just force people to work there yeah
yeah red polos what's that job like it's
weird i only sell the one guy
and he gets it for free and he expects a
lot of customers no no you pay you pay
for it in your own house you to do like
the mobile card thing yeah pick a tip
and you complain every time yeah why why
why do i have to do this why don't you
have the tap enabled yet because
illegally we can't oh right all right
it's you know it's outdated we haven't
updated it yet should have known that
get it
i get it
see that's rich recreating real world
experience but you don't have to do it
with other people yeah
that's pure yeah it's so chaotic out
there
so i put a starbucks in my home
you just build a you build a [ __ ]
strip mall in your home and you're the
only guy who can shop there we should be
rich dude we have great ideas we should
be billionaires i know should we watch a
little bit of chet hank's
uh youtube video he's a youtuber now i
mean i just want to see a bit of it i
haven't watched this yet yeah do the to
the truth the truth about growing up as
a hanks
and then just like go to them
people will project onto you their own
insecurities
hell yeah man
nah you're right
yeah
weaknesses and that's what i didn't
understand at the time if you're a
factor if you have
thought he was going somewhere else with
that i thought he's going somewhere else
with that
the x factor then you're going to
encounter a lot of resentment from
people
that lack that within themselves and
secretly want that for themselves yeah
it just like makes you wonder where did
it come from because neither hank or the
the other son who's an actor no one
seems this way is this just like neglect
i don't know is this 13 minutes of him
just
probably
yeah
this is watermarked hank's fit
self-mastery i still follow him on
instagram and he he's now started he's
gotten super jacked sick and he now
started this program called hank's fit
nice where you subscribe monthly and
it's like life coaching and he like
zooms with the people that have like
premium subscriptions yeah he'll post
about it like just zoomed with
one of my and so he's constantly posting
now about like not going out and
staying in working out
eating right hitting your macros
it's a pretty pretty sick transition
yeah that's that's pretty swift from i'm
gonna be a rapper yeah
very swift
yeah but you know he's a renaissance man
he does it all exactly
um
well cool let everyone go check out chat
[Laughter]
um
yeah what is up you guys it is chet
hanks just i wanted to remind you to
smash that subscribe button don't forget
to hit the bell no dude that's way too
it's more like
so make sure you hit that subscribe
button because out of all the other
people on this platform i'm the only one
who's gonna give you true genuine vibes
yeah
everyone else here is deluded bro not
like me i've tapped in i'm on that next
level
that's why hank's fit is a superior
product because i'm not just telling you
how to work out i'm telling you how to
work up
yeah that's like a that's it you nailed
it thanks man
that's his outro yeah so just memorize
it okay nice nice
you